les dizaines jack lemmon aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un produit très cool
très très très cool très intéressant
c'est ce produit là c'est le asus rog
zephyrus g14 je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez ya quelques mois au mois de
janvier
je vous emmener à las vegas aux crs
[Musique]
j'ai été voir le stand d'asus qui
présentait ce nouveau modèle est ce
nouveau modèle il est vraiment très
intéressant parce qu'il permet de faire
la jonction entre deux mondes qui se
rend compte mais assez peu le monde des
gamers le monde des ultra portables et
tout ce beau monde vient se rejoindre
ici dans ce produit
le asus rog zephyrus g14 le nom est un
peu à rallonge
mais le produit très cool c'est un
ordinateur qu'un format de 14 pouces
c'est un produit qui est plus destiné
aux casual gamer aux personnes qui
aiment jouer mais pas tout le temps
c'est pas une bécane fait pour les
hardcore gamer quoi que vous puissiez
faire qu'elle pourrait pas mal de choses
là dessus je tout de suite vous
expliquer ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
produit vous le détailler vous parlez
des usages vous dire s'il est fait pour
vous oui ou non
alors je voulais tout de suite si vous
ne connaissez pas la chaîne et bien je
vous parle de teck ici alors un peu
d'ordinateurs beaucoup de smartphones
deux mondes connectés différents
produits technologiques je vous aide à
mieux les utiliser vous filer plein de
tutos plein d'astuces des guides d'achat
grand palais donc si vous n'êtes pas
abonné pourrait le faire dès maintenant
vous cliquez sur le bouton et vous
actionnez la cloche est ici c'est une
chaîne de teck donc j'ai pas vous donner
de l' expertise gaining je ne suis pas
gamer si vous voulez une expertise
gaming vous habitez loin la chaîne de
mon pote arnaud sais je vous mets la
fiche normalement il doit s'afficher ici
si je me trompe pas et je me trompe à
chaque fois mais je pense que ce coup ci
c'est bien ici allez voir s'achète il a
pu se produit entre les mains mais par
contre il a une super expertise elle
sera vraiment venir vous conseillez vous
aider donc aujourd'hui parce que vous
parlez de ce produit plus du produit
technologique plus des usages comment
ces deux mondes de la productivité et du
gaming arrive à se rencontrer pour vous
sortir un produit hyper intéressant et
surtout et surtout mais au-delà de ça se
produit il a un truc est pour moi
peut-être un gadget mais j'adore je
kiffe vraiment c'est ça la vous pouvez
venir complètement customisée
je trouve ça absolument génial revenons
ce faire un tour complet aujourd'hui de
l'asus rog zephyrus g14 et ce constat
vaut pour dire ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire moi ce que j'aime
c'est qu'il est extrêmement rasées vous
êtes vraiment cette diagonale qui vient
se dessiner ici sur le capot on retrouve
le logo ici
republic of games
depuis 2006 j'adore le parti pris avec
toute la partie au niveau des aérations
arrière on a bien le nom du produit
effet russes et lorsque vous venez
l'ouvrir il vous dégage un clavier qui
est aussi extrêmement type et on
retrouve bien le message ici rogge
zephyrus on se retrouve vraiment avec un
produit à la croisée des deux mondes qui
va aussi bien aller pour le gaming on
voit au niveau des codes avec les
grosses touches mais qui ira aussi très
bien pour un usage professionnel
les codes gaming on les en va pour les
retrouver notamment au niveau de cette
touche vous les retrouvez également ici
des touches qui sont très grosses une
qui pour qu'ils aient choisi qui est
vraiment cheap et un imam et un
placement au niveau des hauts parleurs
qui sont vraiment très très bien passé
mais surtout un point qui est vraiment
top c'est lorsque vous venez l'ouvrir il
se transforme il se surélève comme une
fusée spatiale qui sait prête à partir
moi je trouve ça vraiment bien très
efficace aussi très très bien pour la
dissipation de la chaleur mais son nom
apparaît aussi dans quelques instants il
est de la même manière extrêmement type
et d'un côté comme de l'autre
cette charnière alain non à s'appelle la
charnière beau lift et justement elle
vous permet de lever l'ordinateur lift
tout en gardant un côté ergonomique
pourquoi ça va vous servir en fait de
repose poignets lorsque vous allez venir
travailler dessus
ça nous permet d'avoir un confort
optimal pour venir travailler sans se
casser les poignets les reposes poignets
sont fabriqués à partir d'un alliage de
magnésium et d'aluminium
tandis que le capot est totalement
d'aluminium il a également 80 empreintes
digitales qui permet de déverrouiller
très facilement son ordinateur
enfin on a un produit qui est vraiment
bien fait super bien fini très fin ça
c'est un point qui est vraiment très
très très bien c'est que pour un
ordinateur de gaming il n'est pas que
gaming mais c'est quand même un
ordinateur gaming puisqu'il fait partie
de la famille drogue
eh bien voyez on a un truc qui est
vraiment tout petit qu'on peut emmener
au travail qu'on n'a pas honte sortir
avec soin l'écran est une dali ps et du
lcd full hd 14 pouces sur la machine que
j'ai un taux de rafraîchissement de 60
hertz et non pas 200 hertz 60 r c'est
bien mais pour le gaming ça plus
rapidement et limite existe plusieurs
config si vous êtes vraiment gamer et
c'est pour vous le taux de
rafraîchissement c'est important et
souvent c'est le cas à l'est sur la
config sang vert après vous pouvez
monter de full hd à ew qhd et notamment
pour les créatifs mais dans ce cas là ça
sera strictement impossible d'avoir un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
qui dit est ce que les multimédias dit
productivité dit
aux jo ici on va retrouver quatre par
deux haut-parleurs de 2 points 5 watts
qui vont venir apporter un son médium
grave et on a deux ou par le réguler
20.7 watts ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est la position des haut
parleurs puisque les deux haut parleurs
aigus sont situés ici vraiment sur le
haut pour vous apporter plus d'immersion
et plus de précision et les deux autres
sont planqués sur le dessous ici et ici
d'un point de vue général d'un point de
vue global c'est pas mal c'est pas mal à
quelque chose près c'est à dire que
lorsque vous prenez votre ordi est sur
la table
le fai vouziers les haut parleurs qui
sont situées sur le dessous va faire
remonter le son est il ya un quota de
plus immersif et un peu plus de niveaux
sonores
le fait d avoir en façade comme je vous
le disais ça vous apporte de la
précision et ça rajoute à l'immersion
donc ça c'est plutôt bien mais dès lors
que vous le prenez vous le posez sur vos
genoux vous perdez en volume sonore
c'est pas génial ça c'est le premier
point est le deuxième point que je vais
trouver un peu moins bon c'est que on a
beau avoir quatre haut parleurs et on se
dit ok c'est plutôt bien on a du dolby
atmosphère et c'est super tu as ça
marche très très bien mais on manque de
deux choses 1
on manque un peu de puissance ça c'est
un peu dommage et le deuxième point on
va manquer un peu en termes de
spatialisation pour va rentrer dans le
dur maintenant avec la question de la
performance globale
ici comme je le disais on est au
croisement de deux univers l'ultra
portabilité et le gaming qui se rend
compte et qui se prennent main dans la
main ça c'est super ici on n'a pas de
processeurs d'intel si on a du matos qui
vient de chez amd
on a un albert eisen 7 4800 hs à 8
heures on a de la sdram c'est la ddr4 on
peut monter jusqu'à 32 gigas de ram le
stockage c'est du ssd vous avez choix
entre de config 512 ou un terrain est la
carte graphique c'est une nvidia geforce
gtx et 1660 et i avec cjga devait ram
gddr5 dédié au delà du côté tech au delà
du côté spécifications techniques fiche
technique c'est une machine qui marche
sera très bien dans les deux univers si
vous n'êtes pas un plan créatif que vous
voulez travailler sous photoshop sous
lightroom et vous vous prenez un écran
en wqs hd et bien vous aurez de la
performance pour faire du multi calque
vous aurez quelque chose qui sera aussi
très bien pour faire du montage vidéo
donc on est vraiment sûr de la
polyvalence pour la party gaming on a
aussi beaucoup de performance sera pas
le monstre qu'on pourrait
potentiellement attendre mais là on est
vraiment sur une machine qui est au
croisement deux univers et comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure pour du cojeul
gamer je fais bien le cross the old
games et bien je trouve que cette
machine avec vraiment parfaite
maintenant il ya la question de la
charge et la question de la charge
allait vraiment extrêmement intéressant
pourquoi parce que vous avez deux moyens
pour venir charger cette petite bécane
vous avez de la possibilité de venir le
brancher ici là ce gros truc là vous
venez vous le branchez vous avez un
chargeur de 180 watts qui voulaient
rechargera très rapidement mais et ce
n'est pas tout et c'est là que ça
devient vraiment génial pouvez venir
vous rechargez également en usb c'est
alors vous habitez de mettre les deux en
même temps parce que ça ne servirait pas
à grand chose mais si vous n'avez pas
votre gros blocs de charge et vous êtes
en mode nomade que vous voulez pas vous
embêter bien vous prenez un chargeur 65
watts voulait charger onu lbc ça mettra
un peu plus de temps que vous pourrez
changer très facilement et voyez c'est
là on est une fois de plus au croisement
des deux univers la productivité le
gaming qui fonctionne chez free une
pétale doigts et qu'il fonctionne main
dans la main pour gaming vous avez 180
watts pour la productivité le
déplacement à côté un peu plus mobilité
vous avez le 65 watts et ça s'est
vraiment affirmé et on le voit une fois
de plus ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de la
charge et la décision qui était prise là
dessus par asus
moi je la trouve vraiment très maligne
la halle avec mes deux doigts et bien
j'ai les deux possibilités de charge
alors tout ça c'est liam direz vous mais
qu'en est-il vraiment maintenant du
point de vue de l'autonomie onomie c'est
toujours un petit peu critique et a
commandé dans les sphères c'est un petit
peu de tri qui en fait ça dépend d'elle
évidemment ce que vous vous allez en
faire si vous faites du montage avec à
côté un lightroom et un photoshop avec
du multi calque vous douterez qu'à un
moment ça va pédaler davantage et vous
allez venir consommer mais je dirais que
si vous partez sur une idée de
productivité et de jouer
globalement vous êtes aux alentours des
6 8 ans on est dans cette fourchette là
une fois de plus ça je viens le tempérer
une modérée parce que ça dépend où vous
de vos usages de vos besoins
si par exemple vous prenez une config
avec un écran de sang versé si vous
montez en 120 hertz salle à consommer
davantage que si vous switchez votre
écran ont 60 hertz parlons maintenant de
la webcam la webcam la webcam là
la webcam la webcam la webcam la webcam
asus a fait le choix de ne pas mettre de
webcam alors savez votre came c'est le
truc dont tout le monde se fout en règle
générale est que personne n'utilise ou
très peu quoique ces derniers temps avec
le télétravail davantage mais en règle
générale
or télétravailleurs tout ça on ne disent
pas beaucoup sa voix de gamme et là
maintenant qu'il y en a pas mal ça me
fait râler pourquoi je vous explique
parce qu'en fait comme je vous le disais
et je le refuse de plus cet ordinateur
est à la croisée des deux mondes la
productivité et le gaming la
productivité lorsque vous prenez pour
travailler et notamment sur les
questions de télétravail vous avez
besoin d'une webcam avec la situation
actuelle les utilisations de webcams
montrent de plus en plus on ne demande
pas avoir la meilleure webcam on ne
demande pas avoir la meilleure
résolution demande pas avoir la
meilleure qualité mais ce qu'on veut
quand même c'est pouvoir se voir
d'autant plus que là dessus vous avez
quand même des micros pour pouvoir
converser
donc vous pouvez converser mais vous ne
pouvez pas vous voir en rond vous pouvez
téléphoner mais vous ne pouvez pas vous
voir donc c'est dommage c'est assez
incompréhensible pour que tes
productivité pour coter gaming également
donc si vous voulez réussir à être vu et
bien il faudra acheter une webcam
externe et ça pour un kit un peu nomade
voilà vous avez compris ici on a un
clavier avec la technologie power stroke
qui vient réduire la distance
d'activation des touches et qui va
améliorer la réactivité du clavier
personnellement je trouve expérience
agréable bon retour de touche
il ya en plus un jeu très sympa fait de
la part d'asus pour trouver ici vos
cartouches complètement identifiée
montesson baisser le son désactivez le
micro vous n'êtes pas désactiver la
webcam parce qu'il n'y en a pas et vous
trouvez votre bouton armorique wright
qui va venir vous ouvrir un mode spécial
où vous allez pouvoir piloter pas mal de
choses mais ça je le développe en
quelques instants
vous avez pas mal de petits raccourcis
notamment ici pour venir switcher d'un
mode à l'autre vous passez sur le mode
qu'ils appellent performance le mode
silencieux vous montez vous baisser la
luminosité du clavier brouillé c'est
très simple on a une très grosse barre
des espaces on a une toute petite touche
enter mais sinon moi je l'avais je
trouve vraiment très pratique pour avoir
c'est ce trackpad alors le trackpad il
est bien j'aurais aimé un tout petit peu
plus grand et c'est le mec qui chipe
audry de pouvoir leur l'élargir un peu
le l'élargir un petit peu là après me
direz vous c'est pour vos repose
poignets donc ça serait dommage de
dépasser son trackpad
ok pourquoi pas c'est un choix à côté de
ça il fonctionne très bien très réactif
challenge bien de la clique de partout
côté connectique on est ce qui va bien
de quoi venir recharger votre ordinateur
un port hd
un port usb ces trois pointes de
deuxième génération avec le display port
et le power délivrés ici vous avez une
prise jack 3.5 qui aura aussi bien pour
un casque micro avec un micro casque on
doit faire de la conférence vocal
uniquement ici on retrouve usb c'est
trois points de deuxième génération 2
ports usb à 3.2 de première génération
et voilà on a fait le tour n'oublions
pas qu'on est dans un châssis de 14
pouces dont on peut pas pousser les murs
on peut pas en mettre plus
ce que j'ai regretté quand on s'adresse
notamment aux 6es côté productif et
créatif qui n'est pas de lecteur de
carte sd ça aurait pu être bien ce qui
aurait été bien aussi pour les gamer
c'est d'avoir une prise rj45 rentrer
dans la partie système d'exploitation
ici autour de sur un windows dix
familles
c'est écrit noir sur blanc ici bon je
pense que là j'aurais pas grand chose à
vous apportez vous connaissez windows ça
marche
parlons du mode armorique krayt vous
allez retrouver toutes les informations
utiles sur votre cpu votre mémoire votre
gpu la température mais vous avez
également accès à votre système vous
pouvez arrêter des processus de 20
moniteurs de ressources
vous avez votre bibliothèque de jeux
votre profil d'environnement vous pouvez
venir paramétrer pas mal de choses
directement ici et c'est vraiment bien
moi ce qui va vraiment m'intéresser
c'est cette partie animatrix puisque
c'est ce que vous allez venir configurer
et qui va s'afficher au dos de votre
ordinateur sa part un peu barbare comme
ça mais en fait c'est très très très
facile vous choisissez votre motif
vous venez vous le jetez ici pour par
exemple ici j'en ai mis deux volets je
vends supprimer 1 j'ai mes paramètres je
vais avoir mon contenu qui est là et ici
je peux venir créer des textes je peux
vous dire mettre un bon vieux monsieur
heureux si je le souhaite peut choisir
toutes les polices que je veux vous
choisissez la taille d'écriture plus
gros plus petit une fois que vous avez
choisi
vous remontez vous cliquez sur à plat
effect et ça va apparaître au dos de
votre ordinateur
on peut imaginer plusieurs utilisations
par exemple vous êtes dans votre travail
vous êtes dans un open space
vous avez votre collègue qui en face
voulu passer un petit message on fait
une pause on va boire un café
vous êtes un afin que vous voulez
envoyer un message aux profs qui ont
façon les gens c'est quand la fin de
concours ou deux mois les réponses vous
êtes en train de jouer vous pouvez
afficher le nom de l'équipe
il ya beaucoup de possibilités de
personnalisation il faut savoir qu'ici
vous n'êtes pas moins de 6500 36
perforation 1215 mini l'aide pour venir
afficher le message que vous souhaitez
la manière dont vous le souhaitez pour
vous ça emmène cet ordinateur dans une
dimensions va choisir de laisser le
message allez activé lorsque vous venez
fermer votre ordinateur vous aussi faire
réagir à la musique que vous allez
mettre alors ici c'est pas si vous vous
rendez bien bien qu'on déjoue le monde
dans le noir comme ça corresponde à la
musique à la sortie de notre ordinateur
la voyez par exemple j'ai mon niveau de
batterie restante je peux choisir si je
le souhaite devenir affiché l'horloge si
je reçois par exemple une notification
au message de voiliers ça me fait
apparaître taxa voilà j'ai une petite un
petit message
et puisque venir les alterner tous les
trois extrêmement facilement avec une
petite transition je choisis souhaite
une transition d'une seconde fais ce que
je veux bon c'est extrêmement pratique
ça marche bien ces coulées sont c'est
assez rigolo on reste sur un usage un
peu gadget il mais je trouve que ça
apporte quand même pas mal de choses à
son ordinateur
en tout cas moi personnellement je suis
assez fan c'est un ordi qui a du wifi du
bluetooth 3.0 qui ne chauffe pas
particulièrement le fait de pouvoir être
surélevé comme ça avec la charnière ça
va aider lorsque vous pouvez sur une
table à mieux dissiper la chaleur
si vous jouez longtemps un jeu
extrêmement gourmand il l'a quand même
chauffe et réchauffer et ses manières
vous chauffer un peu les joue le mieux
c'est de le mettre sur une table si vous
êtes fan de vr prévenir brancher un
casque de réalité virtuelle sans aucun
problème quand est il maintenant des
tarifs et les dispos de se produire tout
est là dessus il ya donc différente
confie que des portraits dans le
commerce je vous en ai noté 2 par
exemple vous avez une version avec 16
giga de ram et 512 ya de stockage nous
trouver à 1799 en arrière droit qu'à une
promo en ce moment je vous ai mis un
lien bien évidemment dans la description
vous pouvez les voir et vous avez
également une version 16 plus intérêt à
1999 à 8,89 autant vous dire qui coûte
2000 euros un docu nasheed il coûte
moins de 2000 euros et qui vient réunir
une fois de plus ces deux univers que
sont la productivité des créatifs et à
côté
le gaming avec une machine performante
qui ira très bien si vous êtes dans
cette catégorie de personnes et si vous
voulez une machine différente
différenciante qui endurante et qui est
performante tout les rimes et pourrait
lui attribuer
c'est un personne que j'apprécie moi
beaucoup il ya effectivement quelques
porcs qui pourrait manquer un homme
viendra corriger
il ya effectivement une webcam qui
viendraient manquer d'autant plus
aujourd'hui
vous pouvez venir corriger avec une
webcam externe mais dans l'ensemble ce
qu'il fait il le fait bien et
partiellement cette machine va bien je
recommande à vous de me dire maintenant
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
être tenté par l'asus rog effet russes
g14
est ce que vous avez
a eu des produits d'asus est moins petit
retour en bas dans les commentaires
wallon se retrouvent extrêmement
rapidement pour continuer à parler texte
croyez moi il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent et appelle choses à dire
beaucoup d'amour des gros déco atterri
quelques uns
ouais
[Musique]